翻訳: Hirona Morimoto
校正: Kyoko Kamura
その日 僕は同僚の宮田と一緒に
お客さんのところに
営業に行ってたんですね
自分は お客さんに提案をする
説明をする役割だったんですよ
だからもう 前日から
「話す順番はこうやな」とか
自分で考えて練習して
お客さんところに
宮田と２人で行ったんですね
僕は うまく話せたと
自分の予定通り話せたということで
帰り道を帰ってたんです
「話せた 話せた」と[思いながら]
そしたら宮田が
「尾中さんが あそこ
説明してたとき
お客さんの反応
すごく良かったですよね
お客さん きっとあそこが
好きなんじゃないかな」と
僕に言ってきたんです
僕 半信半疑だったんですけど
次の提案 それで作って
持っていったら
お客さん 大喜びだったんですね
そのときに自分が思ったのは
お客さんの反応なんて
あんまり気にしなかった
自分っていうのがいたんです
このアドバイスをくれた宮田 —
実は耳の聞こえないDEAFだったんです
彼は僕の声
どれだけ聞こえてたか わかりません
でも声は届いてなかったんですけど
お客さんのことを見てたんですよね
お客さんの心をキャッチしていた
僕は どれだけお客さん不在の
プレゼンテーションしてたんやろなって
本当に反省しました
でも僕
実は こういった経験が
小さいときからたくさんあるんですよね
これが僕の両親です
両親も耳の聞こえないDEAFだったんです
だから僕 赤ん坊のときに
泣いても 親が振り向かなかったんですね
親って 飛行機のエンジン音が
ここでブルルルって鳴ってても
聞こえないぐらいの聴力なんです
さすがに赤ん坊の僕が
どれだけ腹から泣いても聞こえませんよね
そしたら僕こうやって —
これ 我が家では
お腹が減ったっていう意味なんです
おばあちゃんに聞いたら
これが 僕の生まれて初めて
覚えた言葉じゃないか —
話した言葉じゃないかって
言われました
これが 僕の幼いときの光景ですね
僕が長男で 兄弟３人いるんですけど
妹が２人いて
兄弟３人は聞こえるんです
これ家族旅行中ですよね
すいません
いきなりお昼間に男性の裸が
（笑）
すいません すいません
これ僕６歳ぐらいなので
ビールをうまく注げる方がおかしいんですよ
（笑）
溢れちゃいましたよね
そのときにお父さんが
「ゆっくり入れて」っていう
これ 手話なんですよね
家庭内では ほとんどの会話が手話でした
だから それで子供が
どう育つかっていうとですね
手話を話すようになるんです
僕は4歳ぐらいのときは
寝言も手話でした
（笑）
本当ですよ
布団がごそごそって動いてね
手話で寝言するんです
逆に日本語が
ほとんど喋れなかったですね
だから保育園に自分が入ったときに
友達のところ行って —
友達にもなってないんですけどね
同い年の子のところ行って
こうやって手話で話しかけたんです
そしたら話しかけられた
その子からしたら
僕がいきなりこんなことして
（笑）
魔法でもかけられたんかと思ってね
もう忘れられないです
走って遠くに逃げちゃったんです
そうして僕は 保育園では
実は友達ができませんでした
だから 言葉って本当に
人を結びつける力もあるんですけど
離す力もすごいんですよね
だから辛くって 孤独で
お母さんがいつも保育園に
迎えに来てくれたら
もう飛びついて帰って
飛びついて抱きついて
お母さんと手話で話していると
毎日涙が溢れてきました
保育園で遠足があったんですね
みんなで山登るんですけど
僕は楽しみなんかじゃないですよ
友達いないですから
楽しみなんかじゃないんですけど
山登って頂上に来たときに
力くんという男の子がいまして
彼が僕のために
木苺を取ってきてくれたんです
僕に日本語通じひんのわかってるから
僕の前でこうやって
食べてみせてくれるんです
僕も真似して食べて
力くん なぜかジェスチャーの大きい子で
「おいしいね」って僕に言うたんですよ
（笑）
僕も真似して「おいしいね」って言って
帰り道 山下るときは
力くんと手つないで下ったんです
生まれて初めて
僕が友達できた日だったと思います
それが嬉しくって
家に帰って
お母さんに伝えたいんですよね
お母さんも —
初めて僕が泣かなかった日なんです
それは
お母さんもすっごい知りたいんですよ
でも家に帰って
お母さんに伝えようって思った時に
あることに気づいたんです
外で覚えた木苺っていう言葉の手話を
知らなかったんです
だから「こんなつぶつぶが」とか —
まだ日本語書けないですからね
「つぶつぶが」とか
こうやって絵に描いたり
一緒に外に出て
木苺を探したり
それでも 2時間 伝わりませんでした
こうやって体振って伝えたら
また涙が出てきて
お母さんも僕も
泣いちゃったんですよ
日が沈みました
お父さんが 仕事から終わって
帰ってきたんですね
家に入ったら
お母さんと僕が泣いてて
お父さんその状況を
バッと見てですね
真ん中にあった遠足のしおり
バーンって持って
「車乗れ！」って言って
遠足で歩いた山道を
もう1回車で走ったんですよ
車をバンって降りて
家族３人
何探してるかわかんないですけど
茂みの中入ってって
（笑）
僕がたまたま木苺見つけたんですね
「木苺やぁ！」って言ったら
お父さんが バッて抱きかかえてくれて
僕 そのときに見た景色
ほんま写真みたいに覚えてます
今までもここに絵に描けるぐらい
これ 他の家庭だったら
「木苺食べてきたー」って言って
「そんな汚いもの食べたらあかん」って
（笑）
それで終わってたかもしれないですよね
でも うちは確かに伝えることに
苦労したかもしれないんです
でも家族の絆が
本当に深まったんですよね
何より伝える手段なんて
本当になかったんです
でも 確かな
豊かなコミュニケーションが
僕の家庭にあったなと思うんです
これが 今の僕の両親ですね
僕がビール注ぎすぎて
お父さんはちょっとお腹出てきた
（笑）
お母さんは喫茶店やってるんです
10年前にですね
お母さん — 耳聞こえないですよ
喫茶店やりたいと言い出して
親戚集めて「喫茶店やりたい」と言って
親戚はこんな手を振って
「無理やー やめとけー！」って言うんですね
心配事はただ一つで
お客さんの声が聞こえない
僕は半信半疑だったんです
さすがに家族でもね 半信半疑で
お母さんがお店始めたときに
僕 心配で見に行きました
こう 擦りガラス越しに
お母さんの働いてるところを見て
お母さん お皿洗ってるんですよね
そしたらタイミングよく
お客さんがバッて入ってきたんです
そしたら扉開けて
「ママ 灰皿ちょうだい！」って言ったんです
お母さん 自信満々で
お店始めてるじゃないですか
「どんな工夫してんねやろう」と
思ったんですよ
「気づくよね」と思って
「ママ 灰皿ちょうだい」って言って
「お母さん気付け気付け気付け！」
って思ってたら
お母さん 振り向かなかったですよ
そしたら 隣に座ってた常連さんが
その新しく入ってきたお客さんに
灰皿をさっと回してくださいました
お客さん同士 「ありがとう」とか言って
会話が始まったんですよね
お皿洗ってたお母さんも
それに気づいて
「あ ありがとうございます」とか
言ったりしたら
お客さんとお店の人がすぐに繋がって
コミュニケーションとってるんです
笑顔で
「あー不思議なお店やな」と
思ったんですね
でも一つだけ心配なことがあって
閉店後 お母さんに聞きました
「お母さん いつも助けてもらって
ばっかりやったら
お店長続きせーへんと思うで」って
お母さんに言ったんです
お母さんさすがに怒るかなと
思ったんです
お母さん もう余裕たっぷりの笑みで
「一度助けられたら
二度助けるつもりでやっている」
って僕に言ってくれました
お母さんは 確かに
お客さんの声は聞こえません
でも お客さんの顔
見てるんですよね
昨日来たお客さんが今日も来て
なんか元気なさそうやったら
「どうかされたんですか？」って
一番最初に気づいて 気遣いができるんです
だからお店の中には
人間関係が溢れてるんですよね
聞こえないから
もっとお客さんのことを聞こうとしている
相手に寄り添おうとしている
お母さんのお店
今年でちょうど10年になりました
ずっと黒字で続けてるんです
もう珍しいから 全国から
お客さんが集まる店になりました
僕も気づかされました
できへんなんて思ってごめんね
コミュニケーションって
声と言葉だけじゃなかったな
そう思いました
僕の身の回りの
耳の聞こえないDEAFの人たちは
身を以て
相手に寄り添うコミュニケーション
その姿勢ですよね
技術じゃなくて姿勢
それを僕に教えてくれました
耳が聞こえないことって何が辛いか
（手を叩く）
この音が聞こえないことって
何も辛くないんですよ
実は一番辛いのは
こうやって4人で食事とってて
自分だけが聞こえなくて —
みんなの話してることが
わからないんですよね
これって 伝わり合えないとか
わからないっていうことが それが辛いんです
でも伝わり合えない
わかり合えないことって
聞こえる私達にとっても
同じように 辛いですよね
DEAFの人たちって その壁 その困難に
いっぱいぶつかってきてるから
乗り越える力も
それだけあるんですね
人間って強くて
何かを失ったら 何か得るんだなって
僕はそう教わってきた気がするんです
その聞こえないからこそ
身につけた力っていうのは
我々聞こえる人たちが
聞こえるから伸びない力でもあるんです
よし これは
仕事になるんじゃないかなと思って
僕はDEAFの人たちが講師を務める
コミュニケーション研修を作りました
この研修では耳栓をするんですね
耳栓をして チームを組んで
表情とボディランゲージだけで
伝え合うんです
声と言葉を使わないんです
人って日頃 何伝えてるかっていうと
人が持ってるものって
概念とか 感情なんですよね
それを言葉で切り取って
伝えてるんです
だから 言葉使わなくなったら
ダイレクトに 感情とか概念を
共有していくんですね
「目の前の人が
何言おうとしてるんやろう」とか
「目の前の人にどうやったら伝わるやろう」
っていうのを 繰り返しているうちに
コミュニケーションの姿勢っていうのが
磨かれていきます
これを今
いろんな企業さんに届けてます
さっき外国人の方が［スクリーンに］
映ってましたけど
言葉使わないから
色んな外国の方でも参加できます
もちろん 講師を務めているのは
DEAFです
彼らのコミュニケーションの姿勢を
伝えています
耳栓する中でも 一番コミュニケーションが
取れるのは DEAFなんですよね
彼らが 気づきを引き出すっていう
役割をしています
人間っていうのは
言葉っていうですね —
人類最高の発明品ですよね
言葉っていうツールを持ってます
でも 人の心っていうのは
言葉の外にも現れることがあるんですね
例えば
「私か仕事 どっちが大事なの？」って
これって 実はこう言った人って
「私か仕事どっちか選んでくれ」って事を
言ってるわけじゃないんですね
本当はその中にある
「寂しい」という気持ちを
伝えたい 感じ取ってほしいんです
皆さんのコミュニケーションでは
どうですか
その相手の気持ち
心を通わせていることは
できてますか？
「ちゃんと相手に気持ちを伝えたい」とか
「この人の伝えようとしていることは
なんだろう」って
向き合ってますか？
「聞く」っていう手話があるんですけど
こうやるんですね
これが「聞く」
でもDEAFの人たちは 音は聞こえない
でも諦めないんですね
諦めなかったらどうなるか
心に耳が生えてくるんです
これは 「受け止める」っていう
手話になるんですね
これこそが 僕はDEAFの人たちの
「聞く力」じゃないかなと思ってます
僕は今28歳なんですけど
０歳から そういった意味では
DEAFの人たちと一緒に
コミュニケーションの豊かさっていうのを
一緒に体験してきました
そして僕は今
この心に耳を生やす方法っていうのを
DEAFから学べる研修を届けています
耳が聞こえていても —
一番最初に話したみたいに
お客さん不在の
プレゼンテーションをしてしまったり
部下に指示したつもりが
全然違うものが出てきたり
耳聞こえてるはずなのに
話しても 話聞いてない人っていますよね
言葉が 音が 聞こえていても
伝わり合えない
分かり合えないってことは
そこら中に溢れてますよね
DEAFの人たちが
できないことじゃなくて
どうしてもできないことっていうのを
見がちなんですけど
実は「できること」に
フォーカスしていくと
彼らから実は コミュニケーションの
大きなヒントを学ぶ事ができるんですね
28年前から
僕の家庭がそうであるように
コミュニケーションは
言葉だけじゃない
そして 声や言葉のもっと奥にある
「心の声」を聞くことができると
いうことです
DEAFの「聞く力」で
コミュニケーションは
もっと豊かになるはずです
私の話は以上です
ありがとうございました
（拍手）
ありがとうございます